de nouveaux bombardements en cours dans
l'est de l'ukraine le kremlin juge la
situation très inquiétante dans le
donbass la russie soutient les
séparatistes pro-russes les etats-unis
eux redoute une attaque russe de
l'ukraine dans les prochains jours la
russie a annoncé poursuivre ces retraits
militaire par ailleurs le retrait des
chars notamment déployés près de la
frontière ukrainienne qui retournent
dans leurs garnisons retrouve julien
chez id à notre envoyé spécial à kiev
quels sont vos informations sur les
bombardements les tirs des changes en
cours dans l'est du pays
[Musique]
et bien cela s'est produit dans la ville
de bonjour judith ça se produit dans la
ville de stanic à lougansk à quelques
kilomètres de la ligne de front ville
toujours sous contrôle gouvernemental
les habitants ont dit avoir entendu dans
durant toute la matinée des
bombardements répétés pas de bilan
officiel pour l'instant mais ce qu'on
peut vous dire déjà c'est que cela
intervient au lendemain d'un d'une
recrudescence des tensions qui était
avec des bombardements qui s'était déjà
abattues sur cette localité
bombardements qui avaient notamment visé
des bâtiments civils et détruit une
partie d'une école maternelle ce qui se
passe sur place pour l'instant c'est
surtout une guerre de communication avec
des pro russe qui accuse l'armée
ukrainienne d'être responsable de ce
regain de tension en ayant placé des
forces défensives du côté du
gouvernement du côté de kiev le
gouvernement a répété encore aujourd'hui
devant le parlement qu'il n'avait pas
d'intentions offensives vis-à-vis des
séparatistes russe l'organisation pour
la sécurité et la coupe opérations en
europe de son côté a
comptabilisé environ 80 violation du
cessez le feu sur toute la ligne de
front c'est un chiffre qui n'avait pas
été atteint depuis 2015 c'est vous dire
qu'il y a une tension qui est
grandissante sur place c'est vous dire
qu'il ya une tension grandissante sur
place échanges de tirs donc poussée de
fièvre la population ukrainienne se
tient prête en cas d' attaques russes
eh bien on est à 800 km ici à kiev de la
ligne de front et les habitants pensent
qu'un conflit est tout à fait possible
dans le donbass cela fait huit ans que
ça dure il ya un sentiment de
résignation même si ici il n'y a pas de
panique on peut toutefois d'écrire un
sentiment de solidarité nationale
vis-à-vis de tous les habitants de l'est
de l'ukraine tout le monde se sent
concerné par ce qui se passe dans le
donbass on a vu ce matin recueillement
lors
mémorial qui était en hommage aux morts
du soulèvement de 2014 aux morts de
maidan des anonymes sont venus d'abord
assisté à une messe et ensuite ont
déposé des petits anges en papier tout
le long de ce mémorial certains portent
encore qu'une guerre peut être évitée
ici en ukraine merci beaucoup julien
sheridan